welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down the latest DC movie
birds of prey the film is the first big
comic book release of the air and
there's a hell of a lot to unpack from
it throughout this video we'll be
discussing all of the ins and outs on
the characters featured in the film the
themes behind it it's ending and the
post-credits scene there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything about the film runed then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make 'shy subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day and I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of birds of prey and what
terrible crime is that okay so firstly I
won't be doing my typical full plot
breakdown I tend to do as a digis drop a
pot leak video earlier in the week that
covers pretty much the entire storyline
of the film so if you just see it to
learn what happens in the movie then you
should probably click that video linked
above right now and come back to this
one for more of an analysis on the film
rather than just a summary will be
discussing the true meaning of the movie
here and this video on the whole will be
predominantly for people who've already
watched the film anyway birds of prey
picks up in the wake of Suicide Squad
after the defeat of enchantress when we
last saw the clown couple mr. J was
breaking the Harlequin of crime out of
Belle Reve but since then the two have
broken up Hawley has been kicked out of
a house and must now make it on her own
without the protection of a former lover
this makes her a target and it's not
long before people start hunting for her
she narrates the majority of the movie
and it's told mainly from her point of
view though the Joker or rather Jared
Leto isn't in the film his presence
still looms over it largely as do a lot
of the male figures in the piece on the
whole birds of praise about the
patriarchy of society and how females in
the film overcome it it is a feminist
message and whilst I can see that
turning
a lot of people instantly personally
didn't feel like it forced anything down
the audience's throat it was there if
you wanted to see it and it wasn't if he
didn't however I don't think that you
can deny that it doesn't exist it's
pretty much every male character in the
film is bad whether it's the police that
Renee Montoya works with Pauly's
landlord or the villain of the movie
black mask black mask in some ways
controls all of the women in the movie
whether it's a pointing diner Issa's new
driver putting a bounty on Kathy's head
and forcing the females to go after her
and all in all he represents a white
male in power who pretty much does
whatever he wants to the women and his
employee fans of the comics will know
this is a new direction for the
character and the recent revelation in
the marketing for the film that the
villain is gay may put some diehard Dog
Night heads off again it's not too heavy
in the film but it definitely shows that
this movie is striving for inclusivity
and representation Victor Zsasz is his
henchman and he gets let's call it far
more preferential treatment than his
female peers he's viewed is almost an
equal by mask whereas the women aren't
in the comics zaz was a serial killer
that cobb mocks into his skin every time
he made a kill they don't play up quite
how sadistic he is here but he does
become integral to the plot after
cassandra steals a diamond from him this
is a great example of a girl who
represents the new wave of feminism
going against her male overseers and
making a stand that will benefit her
rather than them polymer is this and
initially shows that the Joker has no
control over her by blowing up ace
chemicals this is of course the home of
the character in many depictions and is
also where she was created in Suicide
Squad it's a blast in more ways than one
sends shockwaves through Gotham Black
Mask views her as a weekend defenseless
female and thinks that now she is no
longer under the Joker's protection that
he can kill her without any
repercussions Renee Montoya deduces that
Holly and the Joker have fallen out and
because of this she'll be easy to arrest
renee currently works in the corrupt
GCPD and it's very much at the mercy of
a male superiors they ignore our ideas
take credit for her work hold her in
place enough she must break free which
I'll get into at the end of the video
personally I think Renee is the weakest
of the cast and there was just something
that felt off about her I've always been
a huge fan of the character in the
comics but whether it's this or the Dark
Knight version it's rather they get her
right Renee is a lesbian in the source
material and she eventually ended up
becoming the question she's far better
than what the movie allows it to be and
she's definitely the weakest out of the
group however that doesn't mean the rest
of the group follows suit and I really
enjoyed watching Black Canary and
Huntress make their big-screen debuts
canary initially works as a singer for
masks but after demonstrating her skill
the villain promotes her to his driver
in the film she discovers the cheese a
metahuman and can use her vocal chords
to emit sonic screams the character
would eventually go on to marry Oliver
Queen aka the Green Arrow and I really
enjoyed what they do with her in the
film it's revealed that Dinah is a mole
and black masks organization and that
she's been feeding information to
Montoya
on the inner workings of his criminal
activities in the beginning she seems
like a complete subordinate that will
never leave the umbrella of masks
trappings but she manages to advance
from beyond this and break the hole that
he has over her and her life she's a
strong lead and if we get a sequel I
would definitely like to see a take
charge of the team as it's a great
depiction of the character similar to
this Huntress played by Mary Elizabeth
Winstead steals every scene that she's
in over the years Huntress has taken on
many guises and in some versions of the
comic-book law she's actually Bruce
Wayne and Selina Kyle's daughter this
was retconned over the decades until it
was eventually shaped into the version
that we see on the big screen Elena
Bertinelli has a reputation as the
crossbow killer but a skills go far
beyond that and she's a master of
martial arts similar to the comic books
of Bertinelli was part of a rich family
and she watched them die in front of her
unlike the original work though her
origins are tied more in with black mask
and his mobsters in this movie she was
saved as a child and a like Batman built
her skills until she was in peak
physical condition
in contrast unlike Batman Bertinelli is
driven by revenge
and she now targets gang members in
order to avenge her parents deaths
lastly is Cassandra Cain who is the
biggest departure from a comic book
counterpart in this source material Kane
was the daughter of two world-class
assassins David Kane and Lady Shiva Kane
was a mute that couldn't read or write
however due to the training she received
from her parents she was a master at
reading body language due to this she
could fight anyone on a hand-to-hand
basis with ease because she could read
what moves they were going to make and
easily dispatch them she's one of the
coolest members of the bat family and
also one of the best hand-to-hand
fighters in the DC Universe here her
portrayal feels alien and she's devolved
in several ways that's not to say it's a
bad performance it certainly isn't it's
just a big departure Kane steals a rare
and valuable diamond that has the
location of the Bertinelli fortune and
she sort of becomes the MacGuffin of the
film after Black Mask places a large
bounty on her head pretty much the whole
of Gotham and Holly go after Cassie
Holly becomes fond of her after growing
an attachment introduces her to a hyena
named Bruce Wayne and eventually the
group end up being formed after they
realized that mask is controlling
everything and will kill them no matter
what the plot is rather simplistic but
it is told in non chronological order to
keep things engaging this method of
storytelling has been used in Deadpool
and more recently The Witcher and it
keeps the rather basic storyline from
feeling too predictable
it all comes head-to-head at handover in
which Holly promises to give over Cassie
in exchange for being free of having to
constantly look over her shoulder
canarians as goto retriever and mask
goes back on the deal by instructing
them to betray her it's during this that
sazelin's of canaries alliance after
seeing a text message involving Montoya
and he turns on her Huntress shows up at
the last moment and kills him however
Montoya arrives at the location and goes
to arrest them
Holly manages to convince the group to
work together and fight black masks
incoming goons they all team up as
Warren and it's an awesome action scene
to finish the film with there's just a
bone-crushing satisfying kick to this
battle and it's arguably one of the best
action scenes in a DC movie it was
filmed by the creative team behind John
wick so this does make a lot of sense
and it gives the finale a real punch to
it however black mask manages to capture
Cassie and there's a car chase
well roller skate chase and which Holly
manages to destroy his ride and appear
he holds Cassie hostage but she is able
to kill the character with a grenade now
to me this symbolizes how feminists are
almost taking the weapons of men and
using it against them I'm not saying
this is my beliefs or anything it's just
how I interpreted the film but mask was
pretty much someone who lorded his power
over women but he was literally taken
out by someone insignificant
using his own power against him it's a
symbol that even the weakest can stand
up against is strong and whether
unnecessarily think that that's a subtle
message to end the film on I do think
that the true meaning behind it holds a
lot of weight to it
the me2 movement is about unity and
taking toxic men out by exposing the
thing that they fear the most the true
face of themselves and there's some
subtext to it through black masks
black masks throughout the movie is
someone who pushes himself to be the
life and soul of the party but he hides
a true violent and manipulative face
that becomes exposed during the finale
of the film this symbolic gesture of a
group of women making him reveal his
true face and then take him out does
have a lot to it and yet DC are clearly
putting more thought into their
showdowns or it could just be a simple
action scene and yeah I might be
reaching just a shame that haven't been
so quick to get rid of Amber Heard
anyway I said I'm not getting political
the movie ends with an epilogue of
Montoya Dinah and Huntress forming the
birds of prey this is from using the
Bertinelli accounts linked directly to
the diamond Holly and Cassie pawned the
jewel and go off to start their own
company together
I always did wonder why Holly was in a
birds-of-prey film as typically she's
associated predominantly with the
Suicide Squad in Gotham City sirens
however in retrospect it was out there
in front of our eyes this entire time
the full title for the film is birds of
prey and the emancipation of one Holly
Quinn therefore we know that it was
about the Bo P is one entity and Holly
as another Emancipation actually means
an effort to procure economic and social
rights often for equality and this is
pretty much the main message of the film
which as we've discussed sees women
overcoming the domineering male figures
in their life well Holly is going
exactly we don't know yet but the next
film featuring the character is James
Gunn's Suicide Squad Cassie will not be
starring in this at least that we know
and it is unlikely that you would be
wanted for Task Force X as it's mainly
used for highly dangerous criminals it
is likely that Holly will be captured
once more by Amanda Waller and locked up
she is still serving a life sentence and
will be wanted for the team so I can see
them going in this direction for the
future movie Holly is definitely going
to be going in a different direction in
the next film and she's had a sort of
change of heart since breaking up the
toxic relationship she had with the
Joker going forward it looks like she's
going to be much more of an antihero she
is definitely a mentor to Cassie now and
she's evolved in many ways Cassie is of
course Batgirl in the comics and they
could potentially go this route with the
audio at the end of the film which I'll
get into in just a bit the movie also
leaves room for a birds of prey sequel
that it's more focused on the group and
I would love to see it after this entry
before we get into the post-credits
scene I just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of dr. sleep to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning it's
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on birds of prey
in the comments below but when it's
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
February and the Celt be shipped out
from then Toby gets the prize it's the
best of luck that everyone who takes
part okay so the film doesn't really
have a post credit scene but there is
some audio and a continuation of Harley
Quinn generation who thanks everyone for
sticking around she reveals that she
knows the secret about Batman but before
we ever learn what it is the movie cuts
out now Holly did named her hyena Bruce
Wayne so it is likely at this point that
she knows who he is if you read the
Scott Snyder Batman graphic novel run
that was part of the new 52 then you
will know that the Joker did know who
Batman was however he didn't really care
as he viewed it as just a facade in this
universe both Harley and Joker were
complicit in the
of Jason Todd and it isn't a huge leap
to guess that they figured out he was
connected to the billionaire now what
this could do is allow for Cassie to go
under his wing and be trained as Batgirl
similar to a comic book counterpart we
don't know what they're going to do to
Batman due to the Robert Pattinson
reboot but they could be bringing him
across and potentially tying Cassie in I
don't know how that will happen but
overall I really enjoyed the film and
made for a great watch I was expecting
this to be quite bad but I'm pleasantly
surprised by it as I've said the themes
I've mentioned in this video are there
if you want to look but if you just want
to turn your brain off you can enjoy the
film for what it is birds of prey is a
real blast and I had a good time
watching it and therefore it gets an 8
out of 10 now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the film and what you
want to see in the future comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the new bat suit details
which are going to be linked at the end
we go over everything you need to know
about the upcoming movie so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made if you want to come
chat to us after the show either follow
us at definition whitey or click the
discord link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with heavy spoilers so hopefully we
see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]